alright guys welcome to sheltered this
is week three um and basically what we
are so far is that it's basically oregon
trail but you don't move to the opposite
so Oregon stay you know yeah oh it's got
trying to get a new recruit because he
um well one of them suddenly just died
so you know like that's weird but anyway
um no hmm i got these traps out here got
gun out good good good um basically
we're just some kids and we just we just
need a dad you know we just need a dad
2679 mmm she can broadcast recruits know
that our next recruit when this guy is
done he can probably go and fix this
before we get [ __ ] up
ooh tough choice yeah sure she evil or
no she's fine okay I got that's just
[ __ ] try and kill us okay well this
[ __ ] gotta cancel this and she should
probably go on an expedition actually um
how's the clearing what do we need
rubber the best place for that is
probably a school right
take this Clips the guy had a [ __ ]
shotgun telling you disappeared um yeah
go barging water then take a shower and
then [ __ ] when this guy's out here you
might as well repair this to kink I'm
tired but it's not like a big deal oh
shut okay what you found out there yep
what what corpse I would love to get rid
of the corpse but I just can't exactly
find it
um
all right we'll take all of it
this guy should probably make another
rain barrel right oh [ __ ] we need this
stuff but we're probably to use that any
out for recycler um would cement metal I
guess we could make more space right
she's gonna walk past me huh it's anyway
how you doing um I guess they can just
[ __ ] him clean I just got her to clean
the shelter yeah I got broadcast for
traitors I guess ter d7200 camp getting
Rafa's last time it was a [ __ ] murder
show last time I just says there are
lost the weight lots of [ __ ] kid how
badass
sod all left but corpses [ __ ] siggas
chance oh come on come on fleece fillet
please fillet please sleep yes I can't
think got just [ __ ] scary oh yes this
guy can sleep yes [ __ ] um get rid of the
log I don't really need fuel okay
um yes this [ __ ] can probably make us a
room I feel like we should probably make
a hiding space now like reduces
tiredness okay what do I deke um struck
this and make a bad yes ooh yes I was
right hey that look I don't need this
sand um
and oh [ __ ] I need a hinge Oh totally
done a nail take this hinge
mmm does it work right there but I guess
not
make a real bed I get pharmacy [ __ ] it
now we got like good stuff it's got bass
it's come home right now I don't want
him like a [ __ ] die how's this guy
down mmm deconstruct in and make a good
bit I guess
[ __ ] [ __ ] search it we need [ __ ]
nail at this point 10 at 10 food bowl we
just get rid of that [ __ ] it toilet
ok
um [ __ ] okay I guess
can't make that thing yeah I can I the
recycler no I need so much [ __ ]
plastic
should I make this piping about Saul it
is might as well make it semi know what
the [ __ ] going to happen here
take this and I basically need
everything else yes don't transfer me
ups ooh okay I don't know [ __ ] it i
guess so okay i just do not want to get
in the way of the recycler so I want to
expand this it is would cement metal
okay so i can expand this
oh [ __ ] um should I fix that right ok
and now get the [ __ ] out of here
how close am I to this thing six at a 15
buck soon need some more wood metal pipe
do nothing I we come behind I'm not
doing that this nut shot wow ok
hmm
[ __ ] i really need like a screw you can
make this but i can't [ __ ] make
another bed oh I need a bunch of nails
[ __ ] that I'm just doing this for now
add feel to this [ __ ] okay and if you
have food poisoning at your [ __ ]
fault [ __ ] this do gotta sleep
Shane it okay ah [ __ ] ooh who's this kid
she asleep um buck you better drink some
water and then harvest this [ __ ]
74-67 she's good
[ __ ] I don't have any gas mask um [ __ ]
any plastic
okay go go go how's that one else doing
here good got get good
I want this to be like far away in case
something happens you know that's good
mmm guess we can get here to continue to
trade we need a recycler search it
take all this in case we find something
else so that you probably fix this
search it let's say let's say who now
look too good I'm getting Bob oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] my whitish brown [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what an [ __ ] [ __ ] ooh I'm strong as
an ox oh oh oh wait its arm this [ __ ]
yeah cut him
subdue this [ __ ] what the [ __ ] why is
he she's such a little [ __ ] ow ow
owwwww to solve this [ __ ]
tucson this [ __ ]
[ __ ] I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here oh
come on come on come on come on come on
come on yes [ __ ] a she got [ __ ] up
there oh she won't even tight but Jesus
he is not even a why I go for battling
uh oh uh oh [ __ ] oh wow oh wow
what yes good good good I really liked
how that played out let me take its
blood okay here you can have the arm
trauma has been up Jesus gained the
courage straight finally huh just
[ __ ] love chicken [ __ ]
yes
ooh
what is that a rock [ __ ] you um he does
need this me this give me some fuel wow
sounds very nice to you okay [ __ ] I just
need a little more 15
hey five more
search it I doubt [ __ ] chakra off
recycle bins I don't oh ok why the [ __ ]
would that happen ooh you but these
kinds Grob are no nice crowbars here
ok three more just [ __ ] fair anymore
for me you down out here for 4754 just
meet we got in here it'll fix that whoo
and then add fuel Brenda she looks evil
hmm Beenie these nails um
[ __ ] what do I give her these guys tape
you want tape
ah spring and a valve and I'd some yarn
[ __ ] I'm running low on yarn use couple
fuses yeah you like that don't ya I
think you really want case antibiotics
[ __ ] oh
get that tape back
the [ __ ] I do the tape tape
you
um let's see your 20 all right all right
how do we have like so much meat we
can't even a store it okay how close
their way to this we just need [ __ ] and
three okay okay um we should probably
make another good bed right or seven
nails stove snare trap what is that
satchel what the [ __ ] where did this
come from should I make a trip wire no
good toilet
good stove good freezer metal detector
binoculars [ __ ] there's like really good
stuff here Tenth lock pit sit shotgun
trap Jesus painting special ok Brenda
you're gonna [ __ ] like die out there
we don't do anything at fuel I did just
keep at in that field did we don't you
feel for anything else what's a
integrity to [ __ ] fix it you don't
care about Joshua anyhow ooh and I know
you can all [ __ ] up like that
hey upgrade this yet ooh any more
leather
I gotta start making traps I think
that's the cat corpse right there [ __ ]
up he's given he might as well clean
this [ __ ] Neely's myself around here the
[ __ ] is black rain um [ __ ] lighter to
him these guys
okay let's upgrade this to contamination
bak water
alright i save this episode baby oh baby
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah share
these peeps hello chaps hello Sharon yes
what you got for me me likey yeah yeah
yeah okay how is and doing is our
loyalty good because if it is we're 70
out there and cope [ __ ]
equipped us equipped this and take clip
this get luck where you wish you the
best and shits hitting those kind of
[ __ ] up ND sleeping a good battery for
[ __ ] tag Nicholas yeah yeah water
stored whoo I hope you don't die Shannon
here's ass [ __ ] that's at is there hi
oh [ __ ] I don't know if I could handle
please like mouths uh okay it's not for
taking it for now can't have always
people a lot food though so yes um
actually we can take a look can we okay
well we don't need the [ __ ] um all right
all right guys day 22 so we're gonna
pause that [ __ ] right there and week 3
is done so why don't you go and enjoy
your real week okay because this the
next episodes can be coming soon guys
don't worry enjoy yourself
you